[Music]
bless you boys welcome home all of
Torrance was praying for your safe
return
miracles didn't save me Padre couple of
atomic bombs did that
nor Louie Zamperini aren't you thank you
for what or preserving the pre-world
facility girls
[Music]
people from all over the country wanna
know if you're going to run in the
London Olympics
what's this if you're gonna train for
London you have to do it right just go
nice and easy see if you can make it all
the way around
you think you can run a four seven mile
again I wouldn't be doing this if I
didn't I don't run to run run to win you
will never get me
wherever you go I will find you
are you sleeping well you're having any
night sweats or nightmares I just
thought I'd be able to forget everything
why is God silent my good man suffer
was it he stopped the pestilence was it
he stopped the wars here tonight through
the drowning man
for some type of hope for the future but
there's a lifeline
just reach out
these men did terrible things to you
[Music]
what are you gonna say to them
[Music]
you